and now on book tv's afterwards program
neuroscientist lisa genova discusses how
our memory works she's interviewed by
author and the forgetting podcast
co-host david shank
lisa
it's great to see you this is gonna be
so much fun yeah yeah
but i have to start out by saying
not cool you're a fiction writer
why are you invading our space with with
non-fiction you've already you are
you're already the queen of fiction
it's like you've got this gigantic
kingdom and it's not enough for you you
need to come over to to the non-fiction
writers world and just
just demolish us as well what's what's
going on here please says the man who
writes nonfiction has a podcast and now
is a famous musician
uh no but i i did want to start out by
asking you you've you've written i think
it's five novels right before this book
yep and uh and just to say you've carved
out a niche is is a great understatement
and we'll get to that in a second but
but
um
why non-fiction i mean what what what
what finally tempted you over to
non-fiction and i'm also wondering
is this uh do you see this as very much
a blip in your long fiction writing
career or do you see yourself you know
now more fluidly kind of going back and
forth
so
yeah the reason for writing this the
intention behind this was you know i've
been talking about alzheimer's around
the world for over a decade now and
that's super important work to me
personally i know it is to you as well
i'm really trying to help folks
understand this disease be less afraid
of it
encourage earlier diagnosis and
resources for care and research
it turns out though that every time i
spoke about alzheimer's the conversation
eventually shifted to memory and
forgetting in general and i found that
folks over the age of 40 definitely over
the age of 50 are all really kind of
freaked out stressed out worried ashamed
of everyday moments of normal forgetting
but they don't know it's normal
so they think that you know especially
after a certain age every time i walk
into a room and can't remember why i
went in there or i can't come up with
the name the actor in that movie i saw
last week i can't remember the name of
the movie i went to the store to buy
milk and i came home with a bunch of
groceries and no milk people start to
worry that this is a sign of impending
dementia especially if they have a loved
one with alzheimer's and so the
intention became you know i can
we have enough to stress about in this
world if i can take this off of people's
plates like you don't have to stress
about these things this is a normal
outcome of how our human brains are
designed and it's very distinct from
forgetting due to alzheimer's so i just
wanted to help folks understand sort of
the owner's manual like this is how your
brain works to remember things this is
why it normally forgets
these are things you can do to protect
it and improve it and and here's what
you have to really worry about with
respect to alzheimer's but most of what
everybody forgets every day whether
you're 25 or 65 is totally normal
okay so let me just do one follow up on
my question before we get into the
actual book content and that is you've
written five books which are pretty in
a lot of detail explored
what these various neurological diseases
are about including still alice with
alzheimer's so why did you have to
switch over to to none what was
necessary about coming over to
non-fiction since you do not you do
fiction you're so you know you're such
an artist at it thank you and i am gonna
go back to that and i don't i'll never
say that i'll never go back to
non-fiction i'll say i enjoy writing
fiction a lot more there's just so much
more room to play and run right so my
next my next book will be a novel about
a woman with bipolar disorder um i'll
probably write about addiction um after
that
but i i reserve the right to dip into
non-fiction again because i think that
this served
the non-fiction platform served a really
great vehicle in this case because i
wanted this to feel
like a friendly
accessible conversation with a friend
who just happens to be a neuroscientist
and can explain this to you so i've been
doing this in person sort of one at a
time like people come to me
sort of confessing
you know they're almost looking to get
diagnosed in this very conversation
they're saying like lisa this is the
things that have been happening to me
you know i can't remember names and i
have to write everything down that if i
need to do something later if i don't
write it down i'm going to forget
and there you can see the fear rising as
if they expect me to let them know that
yeah you've got alzheimer's but they
don't and i explained to them what's
going on and i can see
the relief
and so i just this book was it was very
clear that
that there's a need out there to
understand our everyday lives the
everyday moments of forgetting why that
happens and what to be concerned about
what not to be and also to help like oh
if you've walked into a room and can't
remember why you're in there i can
actually help you figure out why you're
in there and at the same time not panic
about it so it really was just um a
mission to sort of you know help
everyone who's worried about memory
worry about the right kinds of things
and let go of the rest right well i mean
this resonates with me on several
different levels as you can probably
understand first of all just as a person
i don't think there's any person over 40
and i'm i'm 54 so i've been living you
know with this with this uh
with this uh anxiety for for a bunch of
years now of of just
having that that not just one panic
moment but just a a never-ending ending
series of
of uh
deep concerned moments where is what i'm
forgetting normal forgetting
is it just getting older is it just me
being paranoid about getting older or is
there something you know that i should
be worried about here and uh and even
though i'm
now kind of trained in in
in being able to understand the
difference even i still like experience
that like that
that feeling and then the second thing i
resonate with just strongly is this as
you say in the book and as you've said
here um literally you you go and you do
all these book talks
uh in my case about about alzheimer's
season your kids about alzheimer's and
all these other diseases and
and what do people want to talk about as
soon as you stop talking is they want to
talk about their own this this fear that
they have personally they want to be
reassured they want to they want to be
told oh you should go see it they want
to like you're their conduit to like you
know to the medical community in a way
so like just putting trying to put those
answers down in a book form and i found
this book just so
personally reassuring and answering
a lot of the questions that i had and
and that i but also that i had started
to answer in my mind for my research but
hadn't really you know put down so
so thank you for that first of all
you're welcome thank you yeah i think
until it's articulated like you may have
a sense of like man i can't i can't find
my phone or i'm misplacing like i can't
remember where i put my phone and i
can't remember where i put my glasses
again and like man what's going on with
me
and i think the misconception
is to jump to oh there's something going
on with my memory like my memory's
failing it's it's getting older it's
impaired what's happening but your
memory probably was never even involved
in any of these instances because you
can't create a memory if you don't pay
attention for the to the information in
the first place so very likely we live
such distracted lives so we're probably
thinking of the very next thing you need
to do and you're not paying attention to
where you put your glasses down and then
later when you can't find them this
isn't a this isn't a failure of memory
this is a symptom of distraction
right really understanding that like oh
when i can't find my phone it was
probably because i didn't pay attention
to where i put it rather than jumping to
oh my god my memory's failing so i think
just really like like you said like
laying it down on paper and seeing it
explained can really help yeah
absolutely so let's talk about what i
think is the very biggest idea in the
book or at least the
idea everything is narcissistic so this
is how i see the world but um
i'm so glad you spent a bunch of time on
this which is this kind of before you
before you get to the before we get in
this conversation to the
the the you know the the ins and outs of
actually how memory works and and and
different kinds of memory things like
that the big idea for me that
um we are not designed to remember every
detail in fact if we were to to design
to remember every single detail we would
not have the the kinds of powers of
intelligence and kind of broad thinking
that that we do have so we are designed
to forget most
the vast majority of the details that we
come across and in fact there are
examples of people who are encumbered by
remembering too much
detail so i if you could just kind of
talk about like in in a big way kind of
how our brains are designed to not
remember most things and then we can
kind of get to
uh you know what what we are designed to
remember and what's working and what
isn't working yeah so again it's really
helpful to actually take some time to
think about what we really do remember
and what we don't because people will
talk about like i don't remember as much
from 10 years ago or five years ago and
they sort of worry about like wow i'm
forgetting a lot of details from the
past and i would argue that you actually
don't remember your most recent past so
uh you know today is monday a week ago
monday can you tell me all the text
messages that you sent and received
what'd you have for lunch tell me about
your morning shower a week ago like we
don't remember so our brains are
designed to remember what is meaningful
and what is emotional
kind of full stop
um
surprising goes in there because
surprising elicits emotion but what's
meaningful to us what matters we
remember
and we forget what isn't so most of our
lives are spent doing things that are
kind of routine habitual
day-to-day same old same old our brains
don't remember same old same old so
we spend much of our days doing the same
things we get up we get dressed we brush
our teeth we have coffee we sit on a
million zoom calls where now our days
are even shrunk even more right we don't
go as many places so if you're feeling
fuzzy from the past year if you're
feeling a little foggy about like
i don't know this year's big blur
it's because we didn't get out and do as
many things like not only it wasn't
different it was the same day-to-day
and our brains forget what's routine um
so
that's kind of most of our most of our
days so if you want to remember more of
what happens in your life you got to get
out of your routine you got to put new
things in it so things that are new and
meaningful and emotional things that
matter to you that stand out that's what
we remember
right all those vacation days in cities
that you never go back to that you can
remember very specific things because
the context of that day was like no
other context in your life right and we
tend to talk about the things that were
new and meaningful and and exciting to
us right so we have the chance to
revisit that memory and repetition of a
memory helps us remember it it
reinforces the strength of those neural
connections so when i did something
really cool and exciting i'm going to
tell my friends and family about it
again and again and that re
reminiscing helps reinforce the memory
too
all right so this is let's dive into
neuroscience for a second you are
literally a neuroscientist you have a
phd in in neuroscience um
and you're basically
superwoman or wonder woman or whatever i
mean you've got it all so um so
um
my question is
very specifically that you just said
that
most of the memories we remember are
either meaningful or emotional and
that's kind of that's what we're
designed to remember most of
is the reason that we remember those
because
of that emotional moment you know the
challenger blowing up or whatever and
we're right there and it's seared in our
memory or is the reason that that's the
memory and that's the event that we keep
going over and over and over in our
heads and in conversations and things
like that which or is it both and kind
of how does that work in the biology of
our brains
it's a bit of both and so right now
actually we're talking about a specific
kind of memory which is a memory for
something that happened
and that's different biologically from
the memory of stuff you know
so uh the speed of light is 186 000
miles per second or you know my birthday
stuff you know
um
the memories for how to do things so how
to type how to ride a bike how to drive
a car
that's different
memories for stuff that you plan to do
later so right now we're talking about
the stuff that happened
which is called episodic memory and
episodic memories memories for the stuff
that happened are really um influenced
and
enhanced by by emotion so if something
happens and it's emotionally neutral i
might remember it but if if it's scary
if it's exciting if it's joyful if it's
tragic if there's a
an emotion built in that at the same
time that will contribute to that
emotion being very strong and
long-lasting
so
biologically that's because there's a
part of our brain called the amygdala
it's part of the limbic system and that
has a lot of direct connection and a lot
of influence over the hippocampus which
is also in our limbic system but the
hippocampus is a structure that is
required for the formation of any new
consciously held memories and so because
of their relationship we have like a
very tight bond between emotion
felt in the the amygdala and hippocampus
which is busy
connecting the the different aspects and
elements that that contain a remembered
moment or a remembered experience
so
on the one hand
emotion strongly influences whether
we're going to remember something or not
um on the other if it's emotional we're
also going to talk about it right
because that's the stuff that that
matters that's the stuff that gets our
attention again it's sort of like you
know it's it's a
positive feedback loop here what do we
pay attention to whoa that was a big
emotion attached to that that gets your
attention
you can't remember something if you
don't pay attention to it right so if
i'm if i'm driving from boston to cape
cod i crash across the sagamore bridge
i've done this thousands of times
i might be 10 miles past the bridge and
suddenly think
did i already go over the bridge i can't
remember
i can't remember driving over a colossal
four-lane bridge because i never paid
attention to it but if something if
someone were standing on that bridge
about to jump off if there had been a
car accident on the bridge um
if i don't know if someone called and
there was like amazing news someone's
getting married and i happen to be on
the bridge
i will remember driving over the bridge
that day right motion really helps us
pay attention which also helps us form
memories right
and i'm i'm this is the part of the
interview where i'm not sure where to go
because there's so many different things
i want to ask you about memory but
the top of mind right now is i think you
talk about in the book um the
how you remember things that actually
didn't happen can we talk about how that
happens because
uh
that's another huge misunderstanding of
that memory is that people have
vivid memories from long ago and some of
the stuff they remember
has been stuff that's been kind of wound
into the story that didn't actually
happen the way they remember remember it
no it might not have actually happened
at all or it might have happened but you
didn't experience it you're borrowing
from other people so let's back up so
memories for the stuff that happened
again unlike stuff you know stuff you
know how to do stuff you plan to do
later
are
very vulnerable
to editing
and change so the stuff that happened
that you remember
is probably wildly inaccurate and people
have done all kinds of studies of
eyewitness testimony um
people who were interviewed just after
the space shuttle challenger blew up or
just after 9 11
and about where you were who you're with
what what do you remember and then
interviewed again a year later two years
later right and their memories are
totally different
two years later versus right after and
then actually these are tend to be
college students too the um there's a
great study out of emory of college
students so these are young people not
people who have you know aging brains
who might be you know memory impaired
these are 20 year olds interviewed
immediately after the space shuttle
challenger who are you with what were
you doing what'd you what'd you see
how'd you feel
interviewed again two years later their
answers don't match
like almost at all
and then shown their original
handwriting they look at that and think
well that's strange
like that can't be right they actually
will stick to their newer false memories
wow yeah i know it's and so it's it's
humbling and then eyewitness testimony
is wrong much of the time which is kind
of frightening given how much we rely on
that to convict folks
um
if i were to show you a video
this was done by elizabeth loftus a
video of a car accident
and then i asked you afterwards um how
fast were the cars going when they when
they contacted each other
you'd give me an answer say 30 miles an
hour if i instead said how fast were the
cars going when they crashed or when
they smashed into each other
you would probably say they were going
faster
so
here's the deal what happens after we
remember something
influences how we later restore it
so
we can only capture what we pay
attention to in the first place right so
if i witness something
if i experience something
i
i knock and my brain's not a video
camera my memory is not recording a
constant
stream of every sight and sound i'm
exposed to i'm only going to capture a
certain part or slice of
what actually happens so to begin with
my memory is biased and distorted from
what some you know what someone else
sees right so
you know uh a 54 year old man witnessing
something might notice different
elements than a 22 year old woman your
memories of the same event are going to
differ to begin with
now here's the weird part of our brain
so every time
we recall a memory for what happens
we have the ability to add
subtract change it bring in new
information so if i if it's after 9 11
i then watch news reports and i might
incorporate some of that information
into what happened immediately after if
i'm on the phone with someone
maybe what she says and what she notices
influences what i remember
um
i might leave some information out i
might to make the story sound better i
might add add some pieces of information
to connect the dots
but here's what happens whatever has
happened in the retelling or the
reminiscing
then gets stored over it rewrites it
it's like saving in microsoft word it
saves over the original memory the
original memory is gone
and so now
it's like the telephone game the more i
retell this memory the further and
further it has the opportunity to
migrate away from what originally was my
first memory of that event
so years later i'm likely to be really
really far
far off from from what i originally
experienced so if you have siblings this
is like a really cool exercise if you
have brothers and sisters
try remember a holiday from your
childhood or remember of an event that
all of you
witnessed so i could you know taunt my
brother tommy remember christmas when i
was 10 and you were when i was 10 you
were eight and i might say you know i
might have a memory of what we got oh we
got skis and we did this and
he might have a completely different
memory of that exact same day and so we
don't know who's the what i try to help
folks understand is you actually don't
know you can't know who's right and
who's wrong in these instances and you
likely both have misinformation in your
own memory
all right so now there are two
follow-ups to that and i don't know
which one to start with but i'll go with
the the first one that i thought of
uh
why why i mean our brains are are the
most fantastic machines ever invented
and and it's probably going to take a
while for that for that to change even
with all the incredible machines we we
invent um these days
why would uh evolution design a brain
that could
change the way we actually remember
something that happened that would and
would give us the
would make us unable to know whether
that memory is a true memory or
something that was then subsequently
kind of edited in that that
that i don't i mean i can understand how
we want to form a big intelligent
picture we want to keep improving on
that
intelligent picture so you get a new
piece of information you you make it
more accurate i guess but
but to not be able to know in your own
head whether this is a true memory
or something that you changed along the
way
and or to even to make it worse as you
said to
to think to insist that it's a true
memory and even when you're looking at
evidence that it's not what's up with
the design of our brains that makes that
possible so the first obvious answer for
me is just that our
our memory system isn't perfect it's so
fallible i mean this is not the only
instance where our brains are not
designed well for
remembering everything
so there's a you know strange paradox
with memory right so on the one hand
if i decided i wanted to memorize a
hundred thousand digits of pi
my brain is capable of that like i can
do that you can do that
anyone can a man a japanese engineer at
the age of 69 memorized over a hundred
thousand digits of pi because he wanted
to
so we can do that we can learn new
languages you can play guitar and write
songs like we can learn and memorize and
remember
anything
and it's gonna forget you know to take
your vitamin later or to return the
library book like it's the strangely
like you know most astounding
piece of equipment ever
imagined and it's a total dance it's
going to make
the bizarrely simple mistakes and so
i don't ex you know i don't have an
exact answer for you but i can also
imagine just sort of you know
evolutionarily wise like
it's a our memories for what happened
are somewhat collaborative it's not
dependent on just you so like i said i
can only remember what i paid attention
to and so i'm going to miss
a large portion of what actually
happened just from the beginning like
i'm going to only have noticed you know
people talk about eyewitness testimonies
if there's a bank robbery if i'm the
only person who witnessed what happened
i might have only seen the gun but not
the gunman's face because i was so you
know focused on the thing that could
kill me i missed his face all together
but someone else who was maybe not in
the line of fire could have seen his
face so maybe this ability to
collaborate on memory
helps us get a fuller picture for what
happened and as a byproduct we
eventually can't tell you know what was
originally my experience versus someone
else's versus stuff we just made up
because we've got great imaginations and
we're great storytellers our brains love
story um anything that we can wrap a
story around and a story that makes
sense our brains remember that right so
so the the viewer will note that i
almost stumped you even i tried and i
couldn't but i i came
closer than some maybe all right so my
next follow-up to that to this little
micro subject is is there any way for us
to know as we're remembering something
that's important
if we really care to know like let's say
we are on the witness stand or whatever
is there any way for us to know or to
have
hints about
whether something is a true accurate
memory or it's something that we've
edited along the way or do we just need
to give up and just
acknowledge that whatever we're
remembering is simply the story we
have taught ourselves to tell yeah i
honestly think it's the best we can do i
think there needs to be an
acknowledgement and again there's you
know elizabeth loftus is a psychologist
and there are others out there who are
sort of pounding the payment pavement
with this message that our episodic
memories are so fallible they can
contribute to a case and making creating
a picture because obviously we we don't
need to throw it out entirely we you
know we if we witness something if we
experience something there is
there is certainly element of truth in
there there's certainly hopefully
there's some it doesn't distort so
wildly that it's just completely off um
but
it's subject to all kinds of errors and
so to just hold someone's testimony as
this is truth um is dangerous so
i think it's a piece of the puzzle and i
think that you know for example if
someone
if you keep a diary and you write down
what happens
on on your days
you're more likely to remember both what
you wrote down and other elements
because what you wrote down can be
a cue and a trigger for other pieces of
them of what happened that day
so it helps it helps you um
it helps
unleash the rest of the memory if you
keep a diary so those can be more
accurate but on the flip side they can
also be less accurate because if i write
something down it can also
limit what i remember to only what i
wrote down and i can
i've emphasized that so much that i
might miss some other things that
that had happened
but i've now
erased that from the memories it's so
far gone because i've now restored
and revisited only this aspect of what
happened that the other pieces have gone
away and you can't convince me that they
they actually
occurred
tricky um eyewitness testimony i think
is is incredibly flawed and i don't
think anyone should ever be convicted
based on eyewitness testimony alone
yeah yeah neurobiologically that's just
that's that's an injustice and it's i
mean i think the you know the the law
enforcement community does by and large
understand that now right we've gone
kind of through a revolution in the last
20 years where at least most
professionals i mean please correct me
if i'm wrong i feel like this is a story
i have been i'm in the memory field so i
so i know about this but i would imagine
that
most at least responsible judges and
attorneys know
this fact
but it you have to back it up from there
because i don't i don't know and i would
doubt that most police officers are
trained in
the
influence of their language on what
someone's going to remember right like
the example i gave of if i show you a
simple video and i change one verb
in my question to you after you watch
the video how fast were the cars going
when they contacted each other or
smashed into each other i'm gonna change
your memory for what you saw based on
that verb so if i'm a police officer and
i'm questioning a witness i'm
interrogating someone or from talking to
someone after what did you see
my language can very much influence
what the person will say they saw and
then therefore what they consolidate
into memory of this is what i saw this
is what i believe i saw so the language
of of what we used to describe what
happened will influence our future
recollection of what happened
so when the interview this interview
ends we can do a we can both rush we'll
really politely
say goodbye and then we'll both rush to
call our agents to see who can be the
first to get a book a book proposal
going on eyewitness testimony
um you can do that i'm writing about my
my agent's on speed dial so i hope yours
is too
uh so all right so so back to back to
the book and back to the kind of meat of
the book so you um
what is more important to you is it more
because you do you do a bunch of really
interesting things in the book is it to
kind of reassure
people
i mean you talked about that reassurance
being kind of the the your your entry
into this book
and and and that kind of pervades the
book to kind of make people make people
who are going through normal things be
under understand that this is actually
the way our brains are built and this is
this is what we're supposed to be
experiencing and that in itself is is is
huge medicine but then you get into
helping people actually understand
uh the the the differences the the the
workings of memory and i wonder kind of
how you thought about as you were
writing the book like how much do i
because it kind of at a certain point
people want to know stuff but they don't
really want to learn the science
you know
science of stuff they want to they want
to understand like kind of the basics of
it so how do you how do you kind of
navigate that
yeah so i
very intentionally did not want this to
feel like an academic textbook i did not
want to be too long of a book i did i
wanted to keep the chapter short
um i wanted each chapter to feel
like something people could take away
with and then tell their friends like it
was easy enough and understandable
enough that they could then tell their
friends oh i learned this really cool
thing about
how memory works or i understand now
what happens when i have a word on the
tip of my tongue
so i think it was
each chapter i was hoping to give people
a little of like here's
let's let's look under the hood like
here's what happened this is how memory
works and uh i didn't you know i hope
it's not dumbed down so much but it's
it's you know i'm not writing
a neurobiological textbook at all
so this is here's how memory works
um here's what happens when it's not
working and why
so and then here's you know there's some
tips in there for you know what helps
your memory so what improves it you know
things like getting enough sleep and
managing stress and um what can impair
it the difference between alzheimer's
and normal forgetting but yeah i think
mostly i wanted folks to
really recognize that you know
there's not a supplement in this world
everybody wants the supplements right
everybody wants the the rabbit out of
the hat or the magic pill
everybody wants the pill for like how do
i
how do i stop having a ward stuck on the
tip of my tongue or how can i always
what can i do so that i always remember
where i parked my car
and there isn't a supplement out there
for this this our brains are designed in
such a way that we're going to forget
certain kinds of things
regularly forever
and
i find that reassuring and not
frustrating or scary i find that and
that's my hope um so that is one of the
biggest hopes and then i think you know
this other there's an appendix at the
back which is you know sort of the quick
hit list of like
what to do to improve your memory
day-to-day because people like that
um
but there's also this idea again that
it's this memory paradox like memory is
a really big deal it's essential for the
functioning of almost everything we do
and our identity right our ability to
remember you know who i've been and who
i am um
but it's also not such a big deal
because it forgets most everything
eventually
you don't remember last week or last
month very well
um we only remember a handful of things
from the past year really really well um
and that's okay
yeah i mean i think there's a there's
like a there's a zen there's a zen thing
in there which is
if you can get there which i don't feel
like i'm you know there all the time but
but i have experienced it before and
that is this kind of
this kind of sensation of well i can't
remember that is really frustrating i
would love to remember you know the the
exact thing particularly as a you know
professional
writer you want to remember the details
you want to be able to report it you
know accurately
but at the same time there that you you
you have this kind of sense of but i
know like the essence
the essence of what i'm saying the kind
of larger point
is there and and the larger point is
there
not that i'm going to fudge the details
i'll like figure out a way to get the
details if i don't have them you know in
my brain right now but if you had to
choose
between kind of having the larger truth
like the the best the most collaborative
perspective the most kind of overarching
perspective on something that happened
uh
and having some sort of like
you know tunnel vision
memory of the actual things that you saw
and heard at that moment in time you
would definitely choose
the larger picture i mean
100 times out of 100 because that's
what's so great about being human is
kind of having that big field of vision
yes so our brains are great at
remembering the gist
of what happened or the gist of you know
a body of knowledge like you read you
know a research paper and you get the
gist of it
and what's kind of beautiful about
living today is that you know life's an
open book test you can look up the
details you can rule it and so this
isn't you know making us dumber in any
way our ability to you know google the
name or google the statistic
we weren't holding all of that
information in our heads before the
internet this is now a way to expand
what we have access to and what we can
know and use and it our brains yeah we
we get the gist of what's going on um i
should say there are there are about 100
or so people who've been diagnosed on
this planet who have highly superior
autobiographical memory these folks
remember in great detail
every day of their lives from like the
age of 10 or so um so they do remember
last week's morning shower and what they
had for lunch and all the text messages
and um
first for some folks this is this is a
superpower so mary lou henner the
actress has this
and um i chatted with her several times
um and she's in the book
and i tried to stump her and i
um couldn't she or you know i'll pick a
date like you know uh august 4th 1986
and she's like oh that was a saturday
and i went you know to visit johnny
travolta and we did like she has the
whole day oh my god she can tell you
what was happening in the news and what
she wore and what the weather was and um
i i threw in a day that actually met her
in new york city and she's like that's
when you came to new york to see me so
she's got it off oh my god
she loves this um there are folks who
have this where it's not the superpower
you and i imagine it would be it's they
can't stop reliving the worst days of
their lives
full technicolor detail
and they perseverate there and so it's
you know lends to sort of paralyzing
depression
um and then there's the folks you know
there's a famous man
a case study in neuroscience his name
was s
um he was studied by
alexander lauria and he he remembered
everything
and could memorize you know massive
quantities of text in a foreign language
and mathematical formulas he didn't
understand and could regurgitate these
in perfect detail
years later
um but he was somewhat impaired in
day-to-day life too because again
there was no background in foreground
right everything was remembered so what
was meaningful was just as remembered as
what was inconsequential
and so he was he was really burdened by
this
yeah yeah
i think remembering the gist is really
useful for our ability to function
all right let me press you on something
you said because i i wanna i wanna i
wanna see if you'll you'll stick to it
the
is it really true that that not having
to remember all the phone numbers that
we used to have to remember like you
know we used to have to remember dozens
of phone numbers just to stay in touch
with people i mean we we'd have you know
we'd have little
books but still
and now we don't we don't remember a
single i can remember maybe one or two
phone numbers
uh that have you know that are that are
old phone numbers like you know that i
grew up with um
and i don't so is that is that really
okay or are we kind of getting lazy
about some
types of memory and is that a little bit
worse would it be better if we actually
did exercise that part of our memory a
little bit more i love this question and
you and i are old enough that you know i
still remember all my childhood friends
phone numbers
and yet i literally don't know
my two youngest kids phone numbers like
i don't know what they are um and that
just seems like bad parenting right
there
i'm talking about myself but yes it does
but here's the question i'd ask of you
because a lot of people
immediately assume this well this is
just bad this is bad for me like i
should be memorizing these things i used
to memorize all kinds of things like
phone numbers right what is it
better for what
how
are you going to improve your ability to
remember other things if you memorize a
dozen phone numbers
no are you gonna are you gonna approve
improve your ability to remember
you know details of the documentary film
you watched or the book you read
or are you gonna be better able to find
your phone when it goes missing if i
memorize a dozen phone numbers
it doesn't translate so yeah we can we
can our br again you can memorize a
hundred thousand digits of pi if you
decided you wanted to
so i can sit down and i can you know
through repetition
and maybe some associations i can
remember
you know my children's phone numbers and
you know a dozen others
i with no problem
it doesn't improve my memory ability for
memorizing other things whatsoever
and it doesn't really improve my life
because i don't need to memorize that i
have it so our phones
um our smartphones are sort of you know
an externalization of our memory it's an
augmentation of our memory and we can
we can job share
the the job of memory with our phones in
all kinds of really cool ways that don't
have to be
um fearful for us you know like so like
i wear glasses because my eyes need help
seeing we don't you know we don't think
twice about that
i can use google or my contacts list to
remember things for me
um to help aid in
remembering and it doesn't impair my
memory's ability to do other things so
it's not like oh i haven't memorized
phone numbers and now i'm just you know
sitting on the couch staring at the wall
drooling like i'm busy doing i think as
a world we're busier and using our
brains more than ever i mean we don't
have enough down time probably right
right right when i was a kid when we
drove in the car we stared out the
window
we looked at the world we went in fox
and just looked at the world now it's
like well i should listen to a podcast
while i walk i should
remember some of that podcast so i can
tell you about it so we're using our
memories a lot
memorizing phone numbers doesn't it's
not cross-training it's not going to
help you in other ways yeah and i i will
say i i think hearing you kind of say it
that way i i think i not only agree with
you but i would take it a step further
this is just anecdotal and it's it's
just again it's just very just me
looking at myself
um which is what i do so well uh but um
i would say that for my own life you
know being now in my mid-50s we can say
that um
i i would say that
i think that my life has improved over
the and that my skills have improved
over the last say 25 years or so
in that i am wiser because partly i just
don't pay as much attention
to every little detail and i think more
about the big picture even in events
where i probably should be remembering
details i actually have trained myself
to pay attention to more of the kind of
big picture and
and i think that's made me
um a more interesting person who maybe
can contribute you know like on the idea
level a little bit better and i don't
want to paint as a zero some game but i
think that
i think that that i don't know it's a
little hunch i have about myself
no i think you're onto this thing so
there's the you know there's the memory
for the stuff we know so that's your
semantic memory it's the accumulation of
knowledge and that doesn't you know
that doesn't diminish with age you know
most people tend to think of like as we
age your memory gets worse
processing speeds slow
down so you start to be like uh
sometimes you you feel you feel like you
can see the wheels turning like come on
you can get there find the word do the
thing so that happens but we don't have
an impairment in what we've learned like
the stuff you know stays with you and so
you have this accumulated body of wisdom
as you get older which is better than
ever you know
now than you did when you were 25.
and
a lot of us as we get older we do we
like you're saying like you have the
memory for the gist you have mem the
memory for concepts and patterns we get
to sort of see we've lived enough to be
able to have experienced and notice
oh there's a similar pattern between
this and that or this concept feels like
this concept or i can now
make conclusions based on this body of
knowledge that i wouldn't have you know
understood or noticed when i was younger
so um
our memories for the stuff we know
accumulate over time and we
as we age are more attuned to patterns
and concepts than we were when we were
right here yeah so you right together
and you this is why they say you know
wisdom comes with age
um
it's in part because of that
right at least that's what i keep
telling myself wisdom comes with age
so um
let's let's get a little dark now
because i'm sure you know your this book
is going to sell i don't know let's say
two million copies so just statistically
is that is a little low
should i say 10 million
10 million let's say 10 million copies
let's say 100 million this book is going
to sell 100 million copies so just
statistically
those hundred million people
and that some of them will pass it to
another person so we're talking about
hundreds of millions of people will see
the book and then those people know
let's say two billion people so
basically the whole world
will come into contact with this book as
it as they should and i'm getting to my
point um some of those people
statistically will either personally be
at the beginning of alzheimer's disease
or know someone be observing someone and
they'll so so
here's
and and same with this interview it'll
be seen by you know probably a billion
people so let's talk to those people um
what what is a disturbing
thing to notice that isn't
a normal functioning you know what are
the things that we look out for where
it's like you know if that's happening
you should probably go see a
neurologist you should probably get a
couple of basic tests mate yeah yeah and
you know what one of the things i'm out
there pounding the pavement about is
sort of is normalizing
brain health and getting people
comfortable with talking about brain
health so you know we're perfectly
happy to go to our
our primary care physician and check our
heart health right we'll get our blood
pressure taken we'll get blood drawn for
cholesterol we'll be talking about
getting a certain number of steps in a
day um but anything from the neck up we
seem to think we have no influence over
and so yeah i think that one of the
things i'd love to see people get more
comfortable with is being in
conversation with their doctor about
like hey here are the kinds of things
i'm
i'm forgetting and yeah and like this is
what my cognitive health feels like
today right okay and then next
appointment we can compare this year
versus last year so what are the kinds
of things that that could be potentially
concerning so i talk about tip of the
tongue in the book there's a whole
chapter on it because this plagues all
of us right like oh what's his name
what's the name of that movie my friend
recommended on netflix
um
tip of the tongue is really common for
all of us whether you're 20 or 60.
it tends to be pronouns so just
neurobiologically speaking pronouns are
like in little neurological cul-de-sacs
and really hard to get to ultimately um
as opposed to just a common word which
is kind of like tons of intersections in
the middle of main street downtown easy
to come by um so if you're having lots
of tip of the tongues for names of
cities book titles movie titles actors a
person's name
don't sweat it but if you're starting to
go like oh
what's the thing the name of the thing i
write with you know the thing
i write words on the paper with a pen
yes like if you're if words that are
common go missing a lot for you and like
this happens to our friend greg o'brien
all day long
you know he can't remember the name of
of the stuff that we use you know what's
the name the thing i drink
water from what's that called glass
yeah so if that's happening
i you bring that to your doctor that's
concerning um if you lose your keys and
your phone
like that's probably an attention
problem a distraction problem not a
memory problem but if you find your keys
or your phone you think
like what what am i what do i do with
this what is this for why do i need this
or if you look at your phone and you
suddenly you're like i don't know how to
work this
if you have that glitch moment where you
that's more concerning that's different
than just misplacing it due to attention
most likely
um people talk about like oh i can't
remember where i parked my car that's
normal and again likely an attention
issue
um if it's something more concerning
like greg and our friend greg o'brien
will
not recognize his car he'll be standing
in front of it and it won't compute to
his brain that that belongs to him or he
won't remember how he got there this
happened folks with alzheimer's i've
heard this over and over again they walk
out into a parking lot and think i don't
remember how i got here
so that's a you know the first thing to
go on alzheimer's the first thing under
attack in your brain is the hippocampus
right which i mentioned is this part of
your brain that's necessary for the
formation of new consciously held
memories so if this part of the brain is
under attack you can imagine that
that information that's recently
happened won't won't go into a lasting
memory so i can't remember having driven
to the store because that happened a few
minutes ago and i really am a little
fuzzy on like how did i get here
or i'll repeat if you start repeating
yourself a lot because you don't
remember that you told someone something
right someone's saying you're repeating
yourself a lot and you don't remember
you're not aware of this like i don't
remember telling you this
um
again this is a conversation to bring to
your your primary care physician and
treat it like heart health people it
doesn't mean like oh if i admit i've got
a memory problem i'm going to fall off
the cliff into end stage alzheimer's
tomorrow
it's like again like heart disease we
have ways we can prevent we have ways
that we can prolong the distance and
push alzheimer's way off into the
distance by doing the right things right
for your brain health so we know that
heart-healthy mediterranean diet can
reduce your risk of alzheimer's and
dementia by half
it's a lot right if we had a
pharmaceutical if i had a pill for you
and said here this is going to reduce
your risk of alzheimer's by half you
would take it right so we know sleeping
seven to nine hours a night is hugely
important and i've got a whole chapter
in my book as to why because i think
again part of the book is like i can
tell you it's super important for you to
get sleep every night this is gonna help
you is going to help you
lock in the
the memories of stuff you created today
um it's going to help you learn new
stuff tomorrow and it's going to prevent
alzheimer's like okay
but i kind of can let that i don't know
i can kind of space out on that it
unless you tell me why like so in the
book i said this is what your brain's
doing while you sleep right
that helps
so you know that
every time you can give yourself seven
to nine hours of sleep it's like i just
prevented alzheimer's a little bit like
every night absolutely like don't worry
about the years you haven't slept
because that's always water under the
bridge if you don't have alzheimer's
today that means that like you're still
okay right you haven't you know all of
that's already done like what are you
going to do now
so um yeah
yeah and i i will say there was a period
in my life a long time ago where i
thought sleep was for suckers and i just
thought i had you know i i i like felt
guilty about getting too much sleep
which is so silly i'm glad that i
still feel that way i just put something
recently to social media about the
importance of sleep it was world sleep
day and uh a lot of comments were people
saying like i get nine hours of sleep at
night and i feel so guilty about that
right we as a culture we are like that
we're like are you getting enough done
like are you are you lazy are you you
know if you're sleeping you're lazy and
it's like um
well let's find the last we only have
like two or three minutes but let's kind
of let's spend one or two of them
talking a little bit people need to
understand sleep is not like wasted time
we again we are designed we all
every living thing every animal needs
sleep why well a big part of the reason
is that our brains are consolidating
these memories right we need that time
to keep our brain in functioning order
from day to day yeah i mean so this this
clipped for me and this is a lot of
matthew walker's work it's
why
would all
living things
have evolved to devote
so much time to sleeping right like
we've spent years of our lives asleep at
this point at our age right right right
at like 16 cumulative years of sleep so
it's like it's not a it's not a state of
doing nothing that's the thing like
we're not conscious for it but our body
is super busy doing things that are
essential
to the health and functioning of every
organ system in our body including our
brains so we needed to consolidate
memories we needed to clear away the
metabolic debris that accumulated during
the business of being awake so that we
don't get alzheimer's
it's vital to your mental health
cardiovascular health not getting cancer
so it's
i think it really helps for folks to
understand like oh my brain and body are
busy cleaning up and doing business
while i sleep necessary business while i
sleep so
it's not it's not a
state of unconscious nothingness
right absolutely get more sleep and
don't feel guilty about it feel
decadent about it feel like you've just
done something great for your self and
just do that every day and and like you
said don't worry about the
the sleep you've missed uh in the past
that's
we've all done stuff
that that is stupid but we can be
smarter and wiser as we go on
um no more we do better yep lisa this
has been such a privilege to talk to you
for an hour straight we made it almost
an hour without mentioning rudy tanzi
i'm just throwing his name out there
because i've never not talked to you for
anything like this and not talked about
rudy so hilarious um and uh and i hope
this book sells the those 100 million
copies
that it deserves to sell and uh and i
can't wait to
see what your next one odds is on and
we'll uh we'll hopefully talk about that
one too thank you so much can't wait to
see you in real life some days yeah for
sure someday soon
all right take care thank you too
afterwards is available as a podcast to
listen visit
c-span.org
podcasts or